>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
All right, everybody comfy?
Everybody happy?
Everybody ready for an
international Women's Day treat?
I am just going to introduce myself
because I want to maximize the time
that I have with all of you.
I could not be more honored and
delighted to have the opportunity
to speak in the Library of Congress
about my area of specialization
on Women's Day, in Women's History
month at a moment when women
in Congress are on
strike and marching out.
It's just a great day to
celebrate feminist voices raised.
And I am going to tell you just
a little bit about who I am
and what I do, about
the exhibit that I have
in the Jefferson Building, thanks
to Meg Metcalf who has assisted me
in bringing so much to
display and exhibit.
And then I am going to play
you a bunch of little samples
with this ancient item that's called
a tape player from the 20th century.
And I'll explain what all the
ephemera is that I schlepped
up to Capitol Hill
bewildering people on Metro.
So I am a women's history
professor and I am part time at GW,
part time at Georgetown
for 22 years.
And my area of interest in women's
history is the women's music
movement of the 60s, 70s, 80s, 90s.
And this is a much
misunderstood phenomenon
which is now just old enough to
start being archived and made
into a sort of serious
topic of study.
And it's a very awkward moment
because there's been critical
backlash against, what are for me,
very beloved institutions like the
Michigan Womyn's Music Festival
and a lot of interrogation of
how inclusive women's music was.
It always has been and we
are also in Washington,
DC very much connected to
local institutions, people,
artists that made women's
music the success it is.
Olivia records was founded
just a few miles from here.
DC is the base of Sweet
Honey and the Rock,
which just lost its premier sign
language interpreter Mama Shirley
so we are very sad about her passing
and I dedicate today's talk to her.
We're located near one of
the best one day festivals
that was ever organized and
that was SisterFire produced
by Amy Horowitz and Roadwork.
Boden Sandstrom started the
first woman sound company here.
This is a really rich region
for looking at people,
places and things in women's music.
And what I want to do is try
to make this a more visible
and serious topic of scholarly
inquiry and popular appreciation.
And I have been introducing
sound tracks in my lectures
for a really long time
and travelling
around the country doing
readings from articles I've done,
interviews with artists, histories
of different women's
production companies.
And what I have is only a tiny inch
of what is in my house right now.
I have one of the best archives
in the United States
of this whole subject.
And beginning at the end of January
I was permitted to have a display
in the Great North Hall of a couple
of glass cases showing a little bit
of the timeline of
feminist music and sound.
And I am going to try
and expand on that.
I brought a few more
things from my house.
But, at your leisure, you can go
over there and look at what kind
of begins with suffrage protest
music and goes right through to punk
and there's fantastic items
from of course the Library
of Congress collection.
And they include the sheet music
to Loretta Lynn's, The Pill,
as well as some of the original
albums by Alex Dobkin and some
of the zines that were
the only media
to promote women's music,
Hot Wire, Paid My Dues.
And we also have on display some
recordings by the group Betty,
a DC based trio of dynamic women.
So, I am going to just start
a little bit, oh my gosh,
with the origins of women's
music and what I have
out on the table is
pretty self-explanatory,
but I will explain anyway.
Ah, we really begin with drumming.
Drumming is one of the
most ancient of the ways
that women created sound, very much
like the heartbeat and the baby
that lies in the womb, but
also often off limits to women
who were not permitted to
join male only rituals,
celebrations, and drum training.
And that remains a very
frustrating issue for many women
in different tribes globally
from the South Pacific to Africa.
And in the spaces around
band instrumental training,
we find women turning to the
obvious lullabies and passing along
to their babies both soothing
sounds and whispered information,
whispered information you know
that was often in a secret language
where women even were not permitted
the regular language of the men.
That was very true in my personal
heritage, Jewish tradition
where in Eastern Europe men
spoke of serious things in Hebrew
and women said rude things
about guys in Yiddish.
And the Yiddish lullabies are filled
with despair about the unreliability
of men and that was considered a
women's language or the mamalotion,
and I will give you a little
sample of that in a minute.
By the time we get
to the Middle Ages,
what we have is a curious issue
where women are composing sacred
music and it's very beautiful.
As nuns, they can go to
a convent or a sisterhood
of living, different kinds.
The baekings are a
different kind of convent.
They were allowed to own
property and eventually leave.
But all of these women were
forbidden to sing in front of men
and by really pretty early
in history there's a ban
on men listening to
women's voices with the idea
that it could turn them, arouse
them, you know, what have you.
One of the few contemporary
artifacts about this,
this is from a Hasidic community
that I studied in grad school,
Rabbinic Advisory, Woman Singing.
Okay, so this would be on an
album warning young religious men,
don't buy this album, there
are women on it, you know.
Okay, yeah I know, so we have
let's say compositions by someone
like Hildegard of Bingen.
And her recordings are available
to us now, if I can find them.
Ah, here we go.
And this is a, she's obviously
not really available to us
at you know DAR Constitution Hall
right now, but she's reminded,
ah we have access to her
recordings through compilations.
This is called Joan of Arc and it is
all music that was dedicated to Mary
from the Middle Ages and it includes
some of Hildegard's compositions
and other songs about the
hardship of being a female.
By the time we get to the Middle
Ages and a little bit after,
we also have well-known songs
that are passed woman to woman
that are very much about the
trauma of an unplanned pregnancy.
So many women were burned as
witches, so many women were charged
with deviant, sinful behavior
and burned at the stake.
And one of my colleagues and
friends in grad school, Deb Symonds,
did her dissertation
on Scotts Ballads
about illegitimate
birth and infanticide.
And that is the book on the table
that's called "Weep Not for Me."
Those songs were very much trickling
down into contemporary folk tunes
and that's something that's familiar
to many of you from Mary Hamilton.
Mary Hamilton's Birth the
Babe and the queen says,
"Get up Mary Hamilton, get
up and follow me for I'm gone
to Edinbro Town and
I'm gonna tell the King
and Queen about your situation."
That is all over England and
Ireland so it's indication
that women were singing about
their situations to each other.
It was just rarely written down and
it was a warning to younger women.
So we have you know sort of
proto feminist music that's
about the reality of the body and
the reality of living conditions,
in particular, all over the world.
Where there is constant warfare,
there are absent men that women pine
for and then there are
men who come in and invade
and they invade physically.
And those realities
are captured in song.
And obviously in the
American version,
what we have in the early
America are slave songs and songs
of survival and struggle and escape.
And the people who have studied
slave songs and work songs
of course have done
enormous, meticulous research
on what was the music
that was actually a map
to the underground
railroad and how to navigate
to freedom by looking at the stars.
And the most famous example there
is, follow the drinking gourd,
and of course that's the Big Dipper.
I always get chills when
I write, speak about that.
That's such an important
piece of our musical history.
So by the time we get to
the Era of Immigration,
we start to get scratchy
recorded music, a little bit,
and there's one group, Libana
that has done a sort of recreation
of sweatshop songs by women
more than a hundred years ago
and these are in Yiddish and
I'll just play you a tiny sample.
A woman is singing I am so
exhausted, when am I going to sleep?
This is never ending.
I am always going to
be you know a tailor.
[Music plays] Okay sorry I can't
do more than just a little bit.
I have so much stuff.
But I can talk about anything that
you hear today that interests you.
I will be happy to go
on for quite a while.
When we get to the era of
suffrage, we actually have
down in the other exhibit some
sheet music from suffrage songs
which are just fantastic.
And World War I is a great
time to study opinionated women
because there were women who were
for the war, against the war,
women who said I don't even
want to talk about the war.
Let's get the vote first before
I lift a finger for Wilson.
And one of my favorite songs
is Who Dares to Put a Musket
on His Shoulder which was a women's
complaint that without the vote
or any political input, she was
having to sacrifice her sons.
Mothers were very hostile
to the Great War
because it introduced three
horrifying new weapons of warfare.
No one had ever seen
before the machine gun,
mustard gas which was the
beginning of chemical warfare,
and then the U boat, the
undersea boat that could
of course sink pleasure
ships like the Lusitania.
And so suffrage songs are the first
sort of recorded feminist music
in terms of how we
see the first wave
and the second wave, and so forth.
But a lot of that is specific
to a kind of community
of activists of white women.
Over here we also have
eventually the Harlem Renaissance
which is going to record
very outspoken Blues
and living outside the
law, songs of survival
from African American women, a lot
of gay women, and people meeting
in speakeasies where
they could speak easy.
So the interesting thing about
prohibition is it brought black
and white, straight
and gay together.
Because everyone was a criminal
as soon as you wanted to drink,
and that was a great equalizer.
So one of the most marvelous
things that I found is an example
of a party mix tape that someone put
together and I bought from a catalog
when I was fifteen and
it's called Reefer Songs.
Trixie Smith saying I'm so high.
A little contrast to
Yiddish suffering,
if we could just get
them together, you know.
[Music plays] I'm so high,
I'm so high [Music plays].
All right, kinda fun.
This is from Smithsonian
Folkway, no Rosetta Records, okay.
This is Jailhouse Blues and
this is an amazing compilation
from the Mississippi Department
of Archives and History.
It's from 1936 and this would
be a woman's penitentiary
where the women were put at hard
labor and a lot of the songs are
about relationships, people who sold
them out and then there are songs
that are original, composed behind
bars, and then there are work songs
that allow women to, like men
on a chain gang or on railroad,
use rhythm and chanting to
focus on repetitive tasks
that you can't say no to.
[Music plays] Alright,
I really like that one.
There's a lot on here that's
referential to prostitution
and the inevitability of when
a woman had nothing else,
having to sell herself and so forth.
That's called, Does Anyone
Here Want to Buy Some Cabbage?
And that's a song that could
be disguised as a market song
but it's about something else.
Thanks for your patience.
I'm trying not to walk away
from that mic too much.
This is just the beginning
of a really rich literature.
Angela Davis of course is the one
who produced that amazing text
of which I teach, Blues
Legacy and Black Feminism.
And of course a lot of the
material reminds us that very early
in the twenties, we have
singing about loving other women.
And it's been a wonderful thing in
the better climate of LGBT rights
for people to be able to do
research on the earliest songs
about women in relationships.
Some of them are very sly
and slash overtly sexual,
shocking to us today.
A very popular inner war tune
which Lillean Faderman rediscovered
was called the Boy in the Boat,
a euphemism for love making and it
warned men who went off to the wars
that while you are away,
the women are swimmin, okay?
And then we have the very famous
Prove it On Me Blues, Bessie Smith
and various other women who
sang this which not only talks
about cross dressing, but the
fact unless you're caught,
nobody could prove you were gay and
get you into trouble with the law.
This is not the original, this is
the cover version by Faith Nolan
who became a big, popular
Afro-Canadian star of women's music.
Whoops, play, have to
do it upside down too.
[Music plays...Must have been
women because I don't like men.
It' true I wear a collar and a tie.
I like to watch the women
when they walk ...] Okay,
sorry you know this
is a tape of a tape
of a tape and this is what we do.
Everything else is
more or less original
and of course people
also send me stuff
because they know I'm interested.
Okay, this is great.
The era of the twenties series,
we have women really speaking out.
They are talking about being in
love with women, they are dealing
with abuse from men,
they are fighting back,
how do you earn a living, how
do you live outside the lie,
how do you deal with segregation?
We are all familiar with the song
Strange Fruit about lynching.
But despite the inevitability of
separating women under Jim Crow Law,
we actually have another moment
of very positive integration
beyond drinking and illegal clubs.
That is World War II
when the men go away,
so do many of the big band players
and they are drafted
and women substitute.
And one of the greatest
stories, of course,
is the International Sweethearts of
Rhythm which was a mixed race band,
very daring, very difficult for them
to find places to stay on the road.
They included a very famous
trumpet player, Tiny Davis,
who was very in love
with her partner,
Ruby and there's a whole video about
their lives called, Tiny and Ruby,
Hell Divin' Women and
they are just fabulous.
That is the subject of quite a
number of films and commentary,
but I'll give you a little bit
of their coolness [Music plays].
Let's get a little bit
more of the whole band.
[Music plays] This is an all-female
orchestra and that's Tiny Davis.
Okay, so you can see that we have
not a straight line, but a wavy line
of female empowerment
leading right up to
where people think women's
music begins which is
with the folk protest
songs of the 1950s.
And on the table I have a
tribute to some other blues women.
But I also have the memoir by the
recently deceased Ronnie Gilbert
who performed with the
Weavers, great lady
and of course they were black-listed
and investigated actually
by the House on American
Activities Committee.
That was the beginning of a
folk revival where many people
because of the investigation
of our government became alerted
folk concerts were a great place
to meet other progressives or
to dare to mix interracially.
There was not very much
of an effective gay rights
movement at that point.
There was the beginnings though
of a Civil Rights protest movement
that would bring people
out of the house
to see difference as
less frightening.
And in this era we have a couple
of women who really emerge
as recognizable figures and that
would include Malvina Reynolds,
Little Boxes, and she did a song
called We Don't Need the Men
and a whole lot of commentary
on what she saw as conformity
in the era and the need
for people to rise.
And after that, the cat is
out of the bag so to speak.
So where I sort of come into this
history would be the beginning
of the 1960s with peace
marching parents
who never stopped playing
Joan Baez albums.
And through the voices
of women in the house,
I came to recognize union songs,
anti-war music, music about women
who had lost men to
war, draft resistance.
Eventually Judy Collins, much
later on, recorded a song
about having an abortion.
That was not something I
heard as a kid but a lot
of those vocalizations made it
possible for me to naturally
to respond to women's music when
it sort of begins in the 70s.
So, what do we call women's music?
Women's music revives in the
early 70s as a kind of response
to the belittlement of
women in rock and roll
where many women were treated
as groupies, as sex objects,
there were a lot of otherwise, you
know, radical and hip male bands
that sang about women in
sexually demeaning ways.
A really good example, the beloved
Rolling Stones, Under My Thumb,
yes there is a problem with that.
And even my beloved, beloved
Led Zepplin, way down inside,
I'm going to give you
every inch of my love.
Really? Okay.
So anyhow, the response to that was
that women began to compose songs
about their lives that were original
and that investigated
the issues of the day.
And one of the first
was Mountain Moving Day
and that album is out there.
That was 1972 and that
was the New Haven
and Chicago Women's
Liberation Rock Bands.
And those are a combination of
songs about sexual harassment,
contraception, abuse in the
home, talking back to patriarchy.
It's just thrilling.
And the title is symbolic,
the mountain is awake
and women are on the move.
That followed a commercially
successful all women's band, Fanny,
with June Millington who now owns
a rock and roll camp for girls
in Massachusetts, as a top 40 hit.
But the feminist music
begins in '72,
and then in '73 we get Olivia
Records and that is the great,
great story that has
brought me into activism.
The story of Olivia is that
a collective of women living
in the Furies House here in DC
who were radical lesbian separatists
interviewed a visiting performer,
Cris Williamson on Georgetown's
Radio Free Woman Program.
And during that interview, Cris
Williamson sort of turned the tables
on the woman interviewing
her and said what do you do?
And the Furies said
everything we do is about women.
We create institutions, we want
women to be able to do things
on their own without relying
on men, and on the air,
Cris said why don't you start
a women's recording company?
And they did the next day.
So that was Olivia Records
which was the beginning
of a woman-owned production company.
It is now Olivia Travel and Olivia
Cruises where I often guest lecture.
And that was very much under
the leadership of Judy Dlugacz
who is still the head of Olivia
and their interest was in trying
to have concerts for women only that
would be uplifting and supportive,
but also which would name the ways
that women were beginning to be open
about loving one another.
And it was a very dramatic change
from what existed at the time.
You had to find women to do sound
and do lighting and production
and all of those skills had
been off limits to women.
And eventually Boden Sandstrom Women
Sound Company which she cofounded
with Casey Culver and
another woman began
to do the sound for these events.
And Olivia's first album,
well actually I have some
of the original forty-five
singles there,
it's the rarest thing on the bench.
They recorded Meg Christian's,
I Know You Know,
which is a really fantastic album.
And it was followed by Cris
Williamson's, The Changer
and the Changed, which to this day
is the best-selling women's music
album of all time.
This was great, but where are
these women going to perform?
And who's going to review
them and distribute the music?
There was no coverage
in the mainstream
of this movement in the 70s.
There was no real way to promote
it without putting women at risk
as soon as it was identified
as something gay.
You could lose your job, your
custody, your standing in church,
your role in a school,
everything if you just showed
up at a Holly Near concert.
So a lot of this history
has a very slim paper trail
which is very frustrating
to me as a historian.
As things digitize, all
that a researcher will find
is what has been digitized
so far, not the complete story.
And the complete story of these
recordings is women playing
in other women's living
rooms with the shades drawn.
And it's in women's scrapbooks.
It's in photos, it's in
memories, it is in oral tradition
which we have to get now.
So I'm adamant about interviewing
women who went to concerts
and their lives were changed.
And it didn't necessarily have to be
about the intimacy
of a relationship.
A lot of what women will
say "saved their lives" was
that the women's music concert
phenomena was an alternative
to the bars.
So it was before Facebook, a space
for the underage and the sober.
The music on stage openly
named everything that radio
and news would not talk about
whether it be domestic violence
or incest, or the lack
of fair wages for women,
things we're still dealing
with now, being an athlete,
being a mom who comes after her
kids, being somebody who is poor,
learning to understand
a person who's ethnicity
and race is different from your own,
being able to consider
running for office.
This doesn't really sound
like you could dance to it,
but actually you could,
you really could, okay?
And a little bit of
our local beloved,
and now missing an interpreter
group, Sweet Honey in the Rock.
Here's an example of naming that
stuff in a way you could move to.
Hang on, by the time this is over, I
will figure out what button to push!
There we go.
So this is Sweet Honey in
the Rock [Music plays].
Alright, that's a song
for something.
Wow, so what's up with WPFW?
Well this is a great little rare
thing from the Washington Blade.
Radio Free Women was kicked off
of Georgetown because they talked
about contraception on the air
and eventually that was not comfy
at a Jesuit Institution,
one where I now teach.
But anyhow the radio station had to
change so the women moved to WPFW
and that became Sophie's Parlor
which is stlll a women's
music show today.
So that's really a wonderful
tribute, again thanks to the power
of local organizing in
facilitating the growth
of the women's music movement.
So on the bench, what I have are a
whole bunch of the albums that came
out of the 70s, some of
which were speech albums.
And the rare ones include
Olivia Records made an album
that was poetry by Judy
Grahn and Pat Parker,
Where Would I Be Without You?
So we have a black and a
white poet reading their work
on the Olivia label.
There was also a March on Washington
in 1979 and '87 and '93 and 2000
and there's a recorded album
from the '79 March for Gay Rights
which is really the
first of its kind.
There was also the first
recording of a festival
and that was the SisterFire Album.
But, in 1977, Olivia also
put out a very famous album
with an orange juice can on
the cover, Lesbian Concentrate.
And that was in response
to Anita Hill's campaign
to roll back gay rights protections.
And that was a wonderful compilation
of all the Olivia artists
at the time.
That's a real collector's item now
and a really fun album to play.
So who was covering all this?
Hardly anyone in the press, except
for two different zines one,
Paid My Dues and then that was
followed by Hot Wire, and Hot Wire,
under the direction of my friend
and mentor, Toni Armstrong Jr.
That I have to go and get.
So what we have in the display case
over in the Jefferson
Building is this issue.
This is my friend Sherry
Hicks on the cover
who is a sign language interpreter.
And each issue of Hot Wire came
with a sampler so you could hear 3
or 4 cuts, this is presuming
everyone had a record player.
And you could be introduced
to the music
and this would cover what was going
on, uh oh there's a photo of me
and my mom at a women's
music festival.
This is an article I wrote, I
Brought Mom to the Festival.
Women's music festivals which began
in 1974 with National in Illinois
and then Michigan in 1976 were able
to bring all these artists together
and offer you, you know, a
slate of performances that went
over a whole weekend and
then eventually a week.
And you could hear as many
concerts as came with your ticket,
relax on a blanket with your
loved one, go to workshops
on fighting patriarchy or how
to learn karate or compost.
There were many more, but those
are kind of the archetypes.
I led quite a few on topics
ranging from Jewish Women's History
to you know journal keeping.
But at festivals, many women
also shared production, touring,
how do you launch a career
as a controversial
person without much help.
Even if you are one of the
best artists of your time,
the mainstream will not promote you.
And these conversations
happened for years.
Of all the people that
performed in festival culture,
four became household names and
those would be the Indigo Girls,
Melissa Etheridge and Tracy Chapman.
And then others had become
better known depending
if you are a Canadian or in England,
Jill Sobule is a good example.
But the problem of course was
that rock media was not interested
in women's music, which was
considered too soft a sound
or man hating or what have you.
And even our own Ms.
Magazine shocked,
shocked to say did not put Cris
Williamson on the cover until 1980
with this concept, The New
Stars of Women's Music.
Yes, she had a best-selling album
in 1974, a little bit late, okay.
Most horrifying we get something
like this Spin, The Girl Issue,
which includes some of, I know,
which includes some of the women
who were performing then,
all over the country,
really articulating
issues of womanhood.
But they were always
reduced to being as fragile
or feminine or whatever as possible.
And then you get something
that's even more obscuring, TIME,
Macho Music is Out, Empathy is In
and the All-Female Lilith
Festival is Taking Rocks New Sound
on the Road.
So this new sound comes 22 years
after everybody else
has started a movement.
Jewel never performed in Michigan,
Lilith is not the first festival.
Everything about this is forgive
me, alternative facts, okay.
And I'm sorry to say we
just see no end of it.
Every couple of years, somebody says
the new sound of feminist music,
even my beloved Washington
Post, okay.
Ouch, A Street Harassment,
right, This Band has Songs
for All of That, 2016, okay.
So there's very little
historic research.
There's a lot of laziness.
I finally got an article Hey Forty
Years of the Women's Music Movement
and Hey Women's Music, You're
Turning 40 in Ms. Magazine,
the soundtrack of lesbian feminism.
So I'm very proud of that and
that only took them 100 years.
And what's surprising is that
you will find terrific advocates
in the strangest places.
And indeed some of them are
sympathetic men and it is great,
so Parade, that little thing that
comes in your little newspaper,
you don't think of that as a hot bed
of radical insight
but groove on this.
Somebody wrote in to Walter Scott's
Parade, "Why are the Runaways
of recent movie fame presented as
the first all-female rock group?
Wasn't that Fanny?
This is a really smart
writer who knows about Fanny.
And listen to the response.
Oh yeah, but even before Fanny there
was Goldie and the Gingerbreads,
the first all women rock band
signed to a major record label,
Decca in 1963 and then he goes
on to give the complete
history like I just gave you.
So Walter Scott, who
knew, long may he live.
And likewise in recent
years students have begun
to write dissertations
on this movement
and it's gotten a little
bit more, more attention.
Okay, just a few more things and
then I'll let you ask questions.
While festival culture
begins to burgeon,
it's not enough to have two.
We start having festivals in every
state so that local women don't have
to pay the expense of flying
to Michigan or Illinois.
So, we had by the late 80s,
festivals in almost every state
including Alaska and Hawaii.
That included Camp Fest, the New
England Women's Music Festival,
the Maine Music Festival,
Lonestar Women's Music Festival
in Texas, WomenFest in New Mexico.
Robin Tyler had two
festivals, the West Coast
and the Southern Women's
Comedy and Music Fest.
There was one in Mississippi
that was attacked by locals
and they were threatened violently.
I worked there for ten
years, Camp Sister Spirit.
A festival in Iowa, one in the
SisterSpace, Pocono Weekend
in Pennsylvania...I'm leaving things
out and I'm going to be killed,
one in the Pacific Northwest.
All of them were completely run
by women with lighting and sound
and one of the most beautiful
artifacts I own is one
of Casey Cohen's light plots
for how to light women on stage
for the Michigan Festival and
that's down at the end of the table.
So, by 1999, I published the
first book on women's music
and festival culture
and I wanted to ask,
Why is this important
to the audience?
I wanted to highlight the
performers and the producers.
I wanted to give credit, but
I was primarily interested
in what the music meant to the
women whose lives had changed.
And starting from the mid-80s, I
would go to festivals, take notes,
tape record everybody's comments
at the mic, take photographs,
and I also passed around
a blank book.
What does this culture mean to you?
Why are you listening?
Why are you here?
How has it changed you?
What will you remember?
And I will show you just an example.
I filled up about five
of these, just passing it
around in a night stage audience
with complete trust, saying,
"Write what you want to say and
just bring it back to my towel
at the end of the concert.
And you know other women were
like partying and making out
and having ice cream and I'm
doing homework in the dark.
But, I'm really glad I did.
And on this one occasion,
the very last page ended up,
"I loved everything about
Michigan," Alice Walker,
sitting behind me,
and I had no idea.
So yeah, careful with
that one, right?
Okay, there is so much music that
I could choose to play for you
and what I wanna do is just point
out a few things and then I am going
to play two more samples then
I will let you ask questions.
One of the things that's
happened with women's music is
that it has really
expanded internationally,
meaning that we have
a feminist movement
with women vocalizing
their concerns now
that we have do it
yourself recording.
So, I have music from
the Sami people who used
to be called Laplanders, indigenous
to Scandinavia; a very famous album,
Stop Excision by women in
Malawi about the problem
of female mutilation; and then
a really important recording.
This is the Irish band, Zrazy
and I will tell you what you
are hearing [Music plays].
67947 double 0, 67947 double 0,
it's a phone number [Music plays].
Okay, that is a disco
hit of the phone number
for abortion information in Ireland.
It was illegal to publish that phone
number in print, so they made a song
that every woman would remember.
That is one of the most
brilliant contemporary returns
to the oral tradition of the past,
can't print the number anywhere
in a paper, illegal to
share, hum it, 6794700, okay.
Likewise, a really rad band that I
love, Girls in the Nose, responded.
In one particular year, there was
a real series of beloved women
at the Michigan Festival who
passed due to breast cancer,
so a really rad band
led by Kate Turner
who is a folklorist made
a rock hit out of how
to give yourself a breast exam.
And we will just wrap
it up with this.
I love that I am playing this
in Federal space [Music plays].
Okay so she was giving instructions
on how to make a breast exam erotic.
Now you are not going to find this
on you know public television.
Okay, well I have so much more
but I am really mindful that some
of you might have questions.
And I want to explain a little
bit about the handout everyone got
and offer a final fun thing.
I tried to type up a little take
away, but I also wanted folks
to have this cartoon
by Allison Beckdell
who of course now has
a hit, Fun Home,
at National Theatre and on Broadway.
In... I'm sorry I have a few more.
In this panel, we see the
awakening of the young woman,
what is necessary to the young
woman coming out in college
at Beckdell's age, and she
and I are the same age.
When you have to be reading
gynecology by Mary Daily,
and you are listening
to Alex Dobkin,
The Woman in Your Life,
on the turn table.
So it's a really terrific expression
of how the cultural material
of the time cannot be separated
from the awakening experience.
And I am so sorry, pass that back
to those who did not get one.
And what I would like to offer
is, before you leave today,
I have this tiny rare
thing, a stamp I bought
at my very first Michigan Festival,
Harmony Through Women's Music.
And I can stamp your
little program, if you want.
And that is something that's not
being manufactured much anymore.
So where does it go from here?
I've donated quite a few items,
in particular Woody Simmons Oregon
Mountains which is so great,
Maxine's Feldman's Closet Sale,
some back issues of Hot Wire,
one of Casey's light plots,
the Ladyslipper Catalog
which distributed through
secret mail all this music,
donated a whole lot of that
to the Library of Congress.
But, my whole collection is willed
to the Schlesinger
Library at Radcliff.
And they came to me, which is
really nice and they are now
in the business of beginning
to digitize the three hundred
and eighty recordings all of
which are on cassettes that I made
over the past thirty
years interviewing artists
and taping sounds at festivals.
So, plenty of work ahead and I will
pause there and thank you very much.
[Applause] Oh, yes.
Who has a question?
Nobody? Let me put on my
professorial looking glasses.
Yes, hi. And where do you
see women's music today?
Yeah, well um, the
problem is as I see it,
is that before we can properly
credit and praise the women
who created all this, we
are in an overlap moment
where the focus is very
much on trans rights.
And there is a big backlash
with if you google different
aspects of women's music.
Younger women are sort
of interrogating it
as it's not inclusionary.
So, there is a kind of
generational dismissal.
And I think in another ten years
people are going to come back
and go, Oh my God, I wish I
could have gone to Michigan.
We are going to be like uh huh.
But, the thing about people
who are now second generation,
Kathleen Hanna and LeTigre
are still doing concerts.
They have like a little
women's history spin.
Then we have women you know
who are very proud to identify
as feminists on the airwaves.
We have very different
versions of all of this
with different new artists.
And thank you for coming.
We have lots of different
movements in different countries
that are just beginning
to dare to record.
So some of the stuff I put out
there, All Female Orchestra
in Afghanistan Dares to
Defy the Taliban, okay.
So women are finding a way to
pass along statements of change
in different means across cultures.
So there is going to be much more.
Obviously I have this ancient
kind of tech so I can listen
to all my old tapes
and albums and my CDs.
I don't even own an ipod.
I'm really 20th century
but I'm also mindful
that many women are
beginning to pass.
We've lost Kay Gardner, Ronnie
Gilbert, etc. so my job is to run
around the country as energetically
as possible and archive everybody
and I'm hoping next to do a book on
women who did feminist radio shows.
And I have been invited
by Pacifica Radio Archives
to do a book based
on their material.
So I'm going to California
in May and I am going
to live there for a while.
And I'm actually being interviewed
on KPFK in LA Saturday night.
This is Wednesday, right?
Next question?
Yeah, hi. Women's music
festivals often had controversies.
Can you talk about that?
Sure, all of them always did.
In the beginning it was should
men be allowed, then boy children,
then what about smoking, then
what about, you know, leather
and etcetera, what about the
problem of racism, what about women
who couldn't afford to
attend who tried to sneak in,
then what about keeping
it safe for children
as more mommies brought babies
and other women were still
desperately trying to party,
then the question of, you know, do
you openly encourage trans women
or do you have, in
the case of Michigan,
a primarily clothing optional
festival that a lot of women went
to heal from sexual
assault and didn't want
to see anyone with male genitalia.
That was written up in
cyberspace in really brutal ways
which were not fair to the festival.
Other festivals always had men
attending or were open to anybody
because they were primarily clothed
or in a dorm or a university space.
My Dad went to SisterFire.
He took his shirt off
and got yelled at
and was told hey, we
can't, so you can't.
And boy, he learned that day.
My Mom went to nine
different festivals with me.
That's how I ended up writing an
article about mothers at festivals.
Ah, she is a very beautiful woman.
She was hit on and
she had to just walk
around with her wedding
ring out like this.
She went to Michigan, two nationals,
two Camp Fests, two Virginias,
one SisterFire and she was able
to meet Ronnie Gilbert who was one
of the few artists of her
generation or older and they spoke
to each other in Yiddish
which was so cool.
As fast as I can write the Wikipedia
page for the Michigan Festival,
someone comes in and
rewrites it negatively,
so it's a constant struggle.
And my argument in the my
latest book, The Disappearing L,
is that it's difficult to keep
up the pace when at the touch
of a button someone can vilify a
culture and send it to millions
as opposed to the limited archives
that we are trying to get online
that are really accurate which have
to be vetted by people who are still
at risk of losing their
jobs if they come out.
And the photos within festival
culture often included nudity,
how do you get everyone's
permission, what about children
of moms who are dragged to
festivals against their will
and are now conservative.
I mean it's really a
sort of historian's,
I don't want to say
nightmare because I love it,
but it's a challenge,
it's a workout.
And being fair to everyone is
a constant moral test for me.
That's a great question.
Yeah, hi. Hi, can you
name some of the top bands
that you feel are important in the
history and also how do you feel
that the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
in Cleveland treats this subject.
Oh my God, it's so
frustrating, very frustrating.
I'm glad you asked about punk.
We put punk in the display.
Pretty in Punk is a
book I have taught.
That's there.
Punk bands, my golly, everything
from, okay, Team Dresh, Tribe 8,
LeTigre, hang on a second, uh, they
are in that film about Seattle.
O boy, I don't have this
written down in front
of me, Seven Year Bitch, okay.
A lot of them have playful names.
And you have to really go into the
Lady Slipper Catalog to see some
of the rare ones, the
Yeastie Girls, Brat Attack.
There's a quite a few
compilations that I have.
They are amazing, but
that was controversial.
That was seen as scary
to a lot of women
who really wanted women's
music to be gentle and sweet.
And Lynn Breedlove who was
the lead singer in Tribe 8
and the title is a
sly play on trabidism,
ancient Greek term for
Lesbian lovemaking.
Tribe 8 had a spokeswoman who
said, you know we may offend
because we're loud and angry,
but we're all rape survivors
and when we jump around on stage
and yell a lot, we feel better
and that's their presentation.
Their presentation allowed
a lot of other women to get
up a do a mosh pit which then
had to be constructed at Michigan
and that was controversial because
what about the women in wheel chairs
who are right down front
and they could not mosh
and the dust was getting...I
mean how is everyone included?
What if you wanted to
dive, do a stage dive,
and you know you were paraplegic?
We accommodate that, okay?
Um, how is everyone included?
Yeah. And the first time I dove off
the stage and you know was carried
around on everyone's
shoulders screaming and yelling
in my plaid flannel shirt,
it was just heaven on earth.
The next time I landed on my head
because people were distracted
and I realized yeah
this could not be good.
But that was part of making
sure at Michigan in particular,
which is really the gold standard,
every genre of music you
would have salsa and big bands
and instrumental, you had comedy,
you had blues, and latina and jazz
and you had in particular
international groups, everyone from,
representing Maori, New
Zealand to China, Hawaii.
One of my favorite experiences
was a native American band Ulali
and they are just one of
quite a few that played there.
So having everybody,
but punk definitely.
And the latest years that would have
included well a kind of combination
of rap, I would say more rap
than punk, Goddess and She,
Krudas Cubensi which is from Cuba,
and then really astounding
impresario performers.
Anyway, it's a great
question and I have much more.
I just have to do a
little looking up of facts.
Yes. Just as sort of a followup, I
was thinking of asking about genre.
When you mentioned Holly
Near, I mean she sort
of to most people embodies the
idea of what women's music is,
but my question is, and
as you have implied,
that is probably largely constructed
by the mainstream audience
in certain ways.
To what extent was there any sense
of a musical taste
or sound within this?
What an awesome question.
So here I have on the
table Kay Gardner's,
Sounding the Inner Landscape.
And Kay was a performer, played
the flute, was very popular,
also played on Alex Dobkin's
album Lavender Jane Loves Women.
Kay argues as, you
know, a musicologist
that there is a specific
female sound and a kind
of circular sound structure
in women's performance.
And she gets very academic with
how if you look at ancient culture,
the sound for what is holy is both
the first sounds we are capable
to make as infants and how the
sacred Hebrew for God, Yahweh,
is just AIOU, Yahweh, right,
and many other theories.
That is a certain kind of sound.
Women who were looking for
something more physically akin
to a drumbeat often complained
that you know women's music was not
for them, but then they
created and added in.
And one of my favorite performers,
Sue Fink, very famously said,
"I don't think we have
women's music,
we have a women's music audience."
So that women would show up,
the same women would show
up for very different styles once
they were, you know, available.
And I think that's still true.
And the interesting thing about
Holly's music, Holly records a lot
of songs about you know
Nicaragua and so forth
that maybe you're not going
to play while you are
relaxing in the bathtub.
Because you know they have
the intention of anthems,
get up and join a work
brigade you know
and in other music the performer
would not be as political on stage
but also might be less verbose and
more a different kind of sound.
And I eventually became
friends with all these people
and became you know a
biographer of my heroines,
which is a really great job,
but a big responsibility.
So how everybody wants
to be remembered,
they all want to be
remembered as broader
in range than their stereotypes.
Yeah, Philip, hi.
I am not going to get real specific,
but what was it about The Changer
and the Change that made it such
a breakout hit or that made it
such a big album during its time?
Well it had all of these anthems,
Sweet Woman, Rising Inside,
I mean various explicit songs
about women in love with each other
and then, you know,
Song of the Soul,
where everybody is singing
together, we will sing this song,
stuff that made everyone
both the particular,
I am in love with someone
specific, and the movement,
there's a whole lot
of women like me.
That I think, both the individual
feeling of awakening and somebody
who was again trained as a
composer and a classical pianist
who had amazing skill
and still is performing.
She has got a new album out now
and that was also sort of an event,
like you would then wait to go
to this concert and what happened
in the audience was
just as important
as what was going on onstage.
And it was like that for me.
I saw my first concert at the Bayou
under the bridge in Georgetown,
it's an ice cream parlor now.
And you know, even in my first
concert, I was writing in my journal
and in my latest book
I talk about that.
It's rude to write through
an artist's performance,
but I wanted to describe
everything because what
if it stopped at any moment.
Nobody was writing about it, no
one was publishing that I knew.
It could disappear at any moment,
and I write that I just
wanted to bottle it like wine.
How many other people
were feeling like me?
And everyone in the audience was,
so that kind of shared experience
was very well captured in the sort
of harmonies that Cris
created and all of the people
on that album are just stellar.
And then the critique that it
was a very white band and some
of the main performers were as well
was answered by Olivia which put
on a tour in '75, The
Varied Voices of Black Women
which took Linda Tillery and
Mary Watkins and Pat Parker
and Gwen Avery and others on tour
around the Bay area and beyond.
Some of that is in
the other exhibit too.
So the appeal of Changer and the
Change I think is a combination
of artistry and that the lyrics
speak to anybody who is coming
into what was unspeakable, following
in love with another woman.
Yes, out of time.
I am out of time, what can I do?
I can stand here, thank you,
and take questions personally.
Okay, thank you all.
This was a wonderful experience.
>> This has been a presentation
of the library of congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov